[Music]
i saw uh the film uh the latest star
trek into darkness and was blown away
it's fantastic and and what i really
liked for you
is uh you get so many great
uh emotional scenes in the film and
action scenes i mean it's a whole new
level for spock that must be jj and and
bob and alex and damon the guys who
wrote the movie
really took spock in a bit of a
different direction this time which i
was grateful for
characters so historically associated
with stillness and to be able to bust
out of that and
i kicked some ass in this movie
yesterday do kick ass did you have to i
mean what kind of training did you have
to have what kind of i are you working
with weights you working with martial
artists what do you have a little bit of
all of it uh we did a lot of fight
choreography and uh and then that was
supplemented by weightlifting and i had
to sprint a lot so there was a lot of
sprint training as well which seems like
it would be easy but it's actually not
well you know what i've always heard is
true is that when you think you're
running cool like you're cool running in
real life when they shoot it on a movie
with a movie camera and show it back to
you it looks horrible you look like a
total doofus i had to do that actually
my trainer i'd be like no no i got this
i got this and then they'd be like
maybe we should tape you and then show
you actually how you look which
they did and then i was like i don't i
don't got this yeah i've seen me running
and it's like
it's like that
i do a lot of waving for no reason as i
said very emotional uh there's some
there's uh real sexual intensity uh in
this serious movie you know in the first
movie i think audiences are really
surprised by spock and who is
relationship yes and in in this movie i
think people will be surprised by the
direction with in which it goes it's not
so
things aren't so copacetic among the uh
crew of the enterprise for a lot of this
film with you and uhura and i like that
spock is going some of the same going
through some of the same difficulties
that all men can have in relationships
uh do you think
if there's another one and i hope there
is that there'll be a vulcan mating
ritual are we going to see that what's
it called i don't know what it's called
oh you didn't know no there's actually a
there's episodes around it yes every
seven years uh uh vulcans have to mate
or die
and so it's a very it's a very volatile
time for the vulcans and you know i've
i've settled up to the writers a few
times after we've had a couple drinks at
a premiere party and just been like
clearly we're going in that direction
for panfara in the third floor so every
seven years or they die i would not have
survived adolescence
i would not have served my 20s
more sad than funny um